In Avengers: Endgame, the heroes who survived
Thanos' destructive snap each faced their
own inner battles, but no one took things
as noticeably hard as Thor did.
The fallout of Avengers: Infinity War grew
even more dire three weeks after the fact,
when the remaining Avengers tracked down the
big purple dude and discovered that he had
used the Infinity Stones to destroy the Infinity
Stones, which spurred an exasperated Thor
to take his battle-ax hammer Stormbreaker
and slice Thanos' head clean off.
"You should have gone for the head."
Fast forward five years after Thanos' quick
beheading, and not all of Earth's Mightiest
Heroes were doing well.
Wracked with guilt over just barely failing
to stop Thanos in Infinity War, and feeling
as though he was responsible for the death
of his brother Loki and the countless billions
who died in the snap, Thor turned to the bottle,
the joystick, and the snack cupboard for comfort.
For most of Avengers: Endgame, Thor looked
less like the chiseled God of Thunder and
more like the Dude from Big Lebowski.
His hair was long and matted, his beard thick
and full, his physique larger and without
tone, and his disposition not nearly as chipper
or confident as it once was.
He found pleasure in grabbing a headset and
talking smack to kids playing Fortnite.
He sought happiness in drinking beer — and
lots of it.
He even guarded himself from hurt by banning
Thanos' name from being spoken in his house
in New Asgard, drunkenly rambled during the
Time Heist meeting at Avengers HQ, and continuously
doubted his own abilities.
So what does Chris Hemsworth have to say about
Thor's evolution from the strongest Avenger
to the down-in-the-dumps guy we saw in Avengers:
Endgame?
Like it or not, it was his idea.
The actor opened up to USA Today ahead of
Endgame's theatrical debut, and discussed
the dramatic change Thor underwent.
He hinted that it was, at least partially,
his idea:
"I just had an opinion.
I wanted to do something different this time."
“We sat for many hours and days and discussed
kind of how far we could push it and what
we could do different.
It was great that was welcomed."
This isn't the first transformation Thor has
experienced during his time in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe, of course — though it's
probably the most shocking.
For the first few movies of the MCU in which
he appeared, Thor had long, yellow-blonde
hair — and was also self-important, serious,
and kind of a brat.
When it came time to close off Thor's three-film
series with Thor: Ragnarok, however, Taika
Waititi stepped behind the helm and brought
a completely new version of Thor to the silver
screen.
"What happened to your hair?”
“Some creepy, old man cut it off.”
“It looks good.”
“Oh, thanks."
He had a cropped 'do, a radically more selfless
personality, an ability to make tough choices
for the greater good and a sense of humor
that solidified him as one of the most naturally
funny characters in the MCU.
Since Thor remained largely the same from
Thor: Ragnarok to Avengers: Infinity War,
it seems there could be something of a pattern
here: a certain iteration of Thor may only
be able to exist in a limited number of Marvel
movies.
Uptight, long-haired Thor was in the hero's
first two trilogy films, along with the first
two Avengers movies.
Goofy, kind-hearted, short-haired Thor was
in Ragnarok and Infinity War.
Now, chubby and self-conscious Thor is in
Avengers: Endgame — and will likely appear
in Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3, as the
final moments of Endgame saw Thor join the
galaxy-faring heroes on their new mission.
Unless Hemsworth has another chat with Marvel
bigwigs on how to give Thor another revamping,
theThor featured in Endgame could be back
again pretty soon.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.